ja auch eine diskussion ist wie wichtig
die zahl der neuinfektionen überhaupt
ist ob das die eine kennzahl ist auf die
wir alle achten sollten wie sehen sie
das
das ist natürlich nicht die eine
kennzahl das ist eine kennzahl die
sollte man auch nicht ignorieren wie
viel sie wert ist weiß man
möglicherweise erst in vier monaten wir
leben im moment eine diskussion dass
sich darum gestritten wird wie hoch ist
die dunkelziffer
es gibt erste studien die modellrechnung
vorgelegt haben das möglicherweise in
der zeit als wir hier 6000 infektion am
tag an die dunkelziffer möglicherweise
zehn mal so hoch weil sie vielleicht
sogar bis zu 60.000 infektionen schon
hatten
ich glaube und hoffe dass wir im moment
durch die großen test mengen die wir
fahren jede woche eine relativ geringe
dunkelste vorhaben aber richtig sicher
sagen kann man das nicht insofern ist
die zahl der neuinfektionen schon ein
paar damit aber ganz wichtig ist
natürlich auch wie verteilen sich die
wie sind die altersgruppen schnitte sind
es mehr jüngere die tendenziell eher
selten erkranken gravierender erkranken
oder sind es mehr ältere menschen wo wir
sorgen müssen dass hier schwerer
krankheit todesfälle in größerem umfang
dann statt in sofern ist das ein
wichtiger aspekt und man muss schauen
wie ist das regionale gesundheitssystem
aufgestellt gibt es überlastung in den
kliniken sind die praxen voll von daher
ist diese zahl eine aber eben auch nur
eine von mehreren genau so wie es auch
das robert-koch-institut hier auf einem
dashboard auch veröffentlicht da wird ja
auch nicht an dieser anzahl fest gemacht
sondern hier wird ja sehr deutlich auch
auf die anderen zahlen hingewiesen und
das ist auch das wo wir von daher mit
dem rk überhaupt kein dissens haben die
eine schreckens zahl ist jetzt momentan
die 50 denn wenn diese incidents zahl
überschritten wird geht man als
risikogebiet es kaum strengere maßnahmen
in ihren augen ist 50 überhaupt der
richtige wert es ist wahrscheinlich der
richtige wird es wird ihnen aber
wahrscheinlich auch niemand präzise den
richtigen werten enden können es ist ein
gegriffener wert und ein wird braucht
man ich finde der sollte dann
tatsächlich auch bundesweit einheitlich
sein damit man darauf gewisse handlungen
aussetzen kann
wir nutzen diesen wert beispielsweise im
bereich der kassen herzlich versorgung
um gewisse maßnahmen dann wieder zu
erlauben
die wir also zuschlagen können
beispielsweise eine telefon nach um die
menschen eben nicht zu unnötigen
arztbesuchen zu animieren wenn sie sich
vielleicht vergnügt führen also hier ist
durchaus eine zahl als ansatzpunkt für
den einsatz von maßnahmen sinnvoll aber
ich glaube man sollte nicht so weit
gehen dass eine zeit bis 50
unproblematisch wäre und 55 ist jetzt
die die das große problem
insgesamt ist es halt
wo ein wert der auch als richtschnur für
maßnahmen gilt muss jetzt haben sie gaal
gesagt vergräbt das wird immer kälter
draußen es ist einfach die jahreszeit
wenn man meine erkältung bekommt wie
schwierig wird das jetzt vor allem für
die vielen praxen wenn leute gar nicht
mehr unterscheiden können haben sie
jetzt eine normale erkältung oder ist es
tatsächlich corona also die patienten
werden das kaum unterscheiden können
krone hat zwar viele symptome die
typisch sind aber genauso viele die
untypisch sind und da gibt es halt
überschneidungen auch mit normalen
grippalen und harmlosen infekten deshalb
die praxen sind grundsätzlich natürlich
auf die grippesaison eingestellt die
kommt ja nicht überraschen die haben wir
jedes jahr
und sie haben alle ihre erfahrungen
sammeln müssen mit corona von daher ist
immer vorausgesetzt dass ausreichend
schutzausrüstung zur verfügung steht der
praxis tritt im grundsatz gewährleistet
und fast alle praxen haben die eben
infekt patienten behandeln so genannte
infekt sprechstunden das heißt dass sie
die patienten die an einem infekt leiden
der möglicherweise dann auch crooner
bedingt ist separat vom restlichen
patienten strom angehen deshalb ist es
ganz wichtig alle patienten die symptome
haben die auf eine grippe oder auch auf
corona hindeuten könnten sollten kontakt
mit ihrer praxis aufnehmen denen wir
aber bitte telefonisch und dann entweder
einen termin vereinbaren oder
gegebenenfalls andere maßnahmen mit den
ärzten und jetzt in gesprächen
mehr nachrichten und bikinis nur weil
die schau dich hier das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren